MARK HARNETT: It's a
fundamental assumption
that all mammalian
species are the same,
but it's really difficult to
actually show that that's true.
So this was one of my
holy grail experiments,
was to look at the
biophysics of neurons,
how different inputs are
processed as they arrive
into neurons and integrate
it together and see
if that's different in
rodents and in humans.
The challenge is getting the
tissue from neurosurgeons.
And those neurosurgeons have
to be research-oriented.
They have to want
to collaborate.
And we did that with
Syd Cash over at MGH.
SYDNEY CASH: We obtained
brain tissue from patients
with intractable epilepsy who
are undergoing neurosurgery
to remove abnormal regions
deep within the brain.
To do that, we had to remove
overlying cortex, that area
of the brain that's thought to
be responsible for higher order
cognitive processing.
We then took that
piece of tissue,
placed it into specialized
artificial cerebrospinal fluid,
and handed it to Mark's crew.
MARK HARNETT: It's
usually Lou and Derrick--
basically are running down
the halls of MGH hospital
and out the door and
into a waiting car.
And then they jump
out of the door
and then run it up to the
lab where we're waiting.
We take it out, put
it into a new solution
that's oxygenated and cold.
And then we have to take this
out and orient it and figure
out, how are we going to set
it up on the slicer physically
so that we can get these
thin sheets of the circuit
to then go on the
microscope that we can then
use to do experiments?
Any misstep at this stage
basically ends the entire case.
LOU BEAULIEU-LAROCHE: So I just
put one of the brain slices
on our microscope over here.
MARK HARNETT: And
under the microscope,
there's this moment in
which we bring the brain
slice into focus, and sometimes
there's just nothing there.
It's just dead.
But other times--
LOU BEAULIEU-LAROCHE:
Here's a neuron there.
There's another one here.
MARK HARNETT: It's just filled
with live, fat, happy, juicy
looking neurons.
LOU BEAULIEU-LAROCHE:
So I'm going to be here
for 20 hours or something.
MARK HARNETT:
Everyone's very excited
because it means
two days of data.
So the technique that we use to
record the electrical activity
from these neurons is
called patch clamping.
The key principle is you
take a piece of glass tubing,
and you pull it into a
little tiny hollow needle,
and then you fill it with
an electrolyte solution.
So this glass needle
becomes an electrode.
MATHIEU LAFOURCADE:
And now I'm going
to fill the pipette
with some dye.
MARK HARNETT: And the glass has
a really fascinating property,
in that it adheres very, very
tightly to the cell membrane.
But this is one
of the challenges
to doing these
experiments-- is you've got
to make one of these pipettes.
You got to fill it with
electrolyte solution.
You got to put it on the ring.
You've got to find
a neuron that you're
interested in, that looks
good, that's healthy.
Then you got to get your
electrode down in there
into the solution
next to the neuron.
It's like playing a
neuroscience video game.
MATHIEU LAFOURCADE:
So now I'm going
to put some positive
pressure because this
is connected to the pipettes.
MARK HARNETT: You then push
the pipette into the neuron,
and then you release
the pressure.
And this little
piece of membrane
now gets sucked up
into the pipette,
and then you can gain
intracellular access
to the inside of that cell.
You can also use it to
fill the neuron with dye
so you can reveal the
architecture of those neurons.
And then you can correlate the
architecture of the structure
with the function.
And so what Lou was trying to
do is have a recording electrode
near the soma but then
another electrode far away,
out in the antenna
structure, the dendrites,
to see what kinds of local
processing operations
are taking place out
there and then how
that dendrite communicates
with the soma.
And so we started
to do experiments
by just looking at
the dendrites that
are the closest to the soma.
In that space, things
look very, very similar.
So on one hand, that was a
little bit disappointing.
We were expecting
specializations
that made us human.
But on the other hand,
it's reassuring because--
OK, rodents are a
really good model.
The past 50 years of doing
experiments in rodents
makes sense.
They're an excellent
model system.
Where we started
to see differences
was when we looked into the
very far away dendrites,
the ones that are much,
much longer than what
you see in that rodents.
And there, we see that their
behavior is very different.
Those very distal dendrites are
integrating a bunch of inputs
independently of what's
happening at the soma.
So the human neurons form
their own individual kinds
of neural networks.
It's a network inside a neuron.
So that conditional
kinds of interaction
supports a very particular
mode of computation
in the human neurons,
so that's what we're
starting to see evidence for.
MATHIEU LAFOURCADE:
Red Bull and coffee.
And-- no, no, no--
passion for science, of course.